Hello everyone, my name is Igor Rachenko and I am the new official org mode maintainer.
Today I will briefly introduce myself and then share my ideas about the future of org mode development.
I will start by passing the word from bushing in the previous maintainer. Then I will tell you a
little bit about my story starting from earlier org mode user all the way to the maintainer.
Then I will detail the new directions of development and specific features which I want to see
in org mode in the coming years. And I will conclude by asking you org mode users to
contribute to org mode because all the features we shot too many can only be implemented with
the help of the community, the help of more contributors. And for that of course I will also talk
about org community and how I see to how I see it evolve and so that we have a good communication
between the development of org mode and community ideas. Let me first pass the word to bushing in.
Hello everyone, Igor Rachenko is the new org mode maintainer. He's been acting as such for
a couple of years now and I'm really glad he's finally agreed to take on the role officially.
As maintainer I have probably done a few things right and certainly made many mistakes.
Here are four lessons I've learned in 14 years. The first is that maintaining
org mode isn't just about code, it's mostly about users. Of course some of them will never learn
how to report bugs, some of them will behave like spoiled children and most of them will expect
you to work for free forever. Nevertheless the time is as valuable as yours, whatever the request
there is always something that can lead to a positive outcome for org mode or its community.
The second lesson is that maintenance isn't just about technical choices,
it's also about predictability, be very clear and very loud about what users and
contributors can expect of your time, skills and motivations. Stick to the robustness
principle by being liberal in what you accept and strict in what you produce.
Thirdly, it's all about learning. Let's build a culture together where it's okay to ask stupid
questions. No one is born knowing how to write in English how to report a bug or how to maintain
a large piece of code. Remember that all diamonds when newbies and that newbies could become
maintainers. We all have a lot to learn, even if it's just how to respect each other.
Finally, as a maintainer, think about the next one. Who will be in your shoes next? What kind of
maintainer do you want for a software you will be using for decades? It's also a responsibility
of the org mode community. How can we collectively attract a maintainer that want to help us use
and enhance this wonderful little tool? How can we, as org mode users, help ego pay the way for the
next maintainers? Enough said, I'm confident org mode is in good hands and I'm very happy user.
Thanks everyone for all these years of fun and learning.
I'll back to my talk. Let me start by briefly introducing myself. I'm actually not a programmer
by training on material scientists and I only started using EMAX and org mode and we'll naturally
do it in programming because that's EMAX. When I was doing my PhD and I wanted to use org mode
to tame my research work. A couple of years I was just an ordinary user until I learned enough
and got enough courage to report my first bug and then it all evolved over the years.
I started bicepating in the main list. I started learning more about elisp. I reported more
complex bugs. I eventually got around to go and fix the tricky bugs. Then I started participating
more in org mailing list in help in fixing bugs. In selected areas of org mode and eventually
switching to all parts of org. So at some point I ended up doing the de-park to maintainers job
to get a bit passed in and got an actual maintenance offer which I accepted recently.
The key takeaway I want you to get from here is that you don't have to be a programmer. You don't have
to know elisp to contribute. You don't and you don't even have to be like that to become a maintainer.
All it takes is slow methodical persistent learning over the years participating in the community
and eventually submitting your purchase upstream and eventually you can become a maintainer.
Oh, not a maintainer, it's as you wish. Enough about me. Let's talk about what I think should
happen with org mode and what my proposal on org mode is. The first and top priority for me is the
basics. The basics, the code-based stability, basically all the foundations, all the APIs in org mode,
all the basic libraries for which everything builds upon so that we have fewer bugs and we have
more understandable code so that others who want to contribute have easier time understanding what
is going on in the code base and contribute without much of a problem or confusion.
Second, equally important direction is the org community because a single person even
a couple of people cannot really develop such a big project as org mode and we always want new
contributors which are not coming from nowhere. We need to have the community of users, we have
community of people who participate in discussions, who later submit purchase and
we code and that's where we get all most of the new features. So I would like to improve the
communication between our community and the development. The third direction I want to pursue is
making life easier for a third-party packages because it's not, you don't only have org mode
as it's distributed within a month. We have a lot of alpha packages, we have a lot of
multiple packages and people, one who want some specific features on top of org mode,
do develop these packages which are widely used and also widely used and it's not only about
amongst we have a lot of mobile apps that can work with org files. We have a lot of parts which
enable these mobile apps or in general programs outside the list for understand org files.
What's direction is the org markup as a foundation of org mode as a major mode because we have a lot
of functionality in org mode itself inside the max but it's all based on the underlying markup
and markup should have enough features to support the pungulance we want to see there.
And last direction is somewhat less important mostly because I don't have that much time to
focus on everything is the new features. I do want to see certain important features in org mode
but I usually cannot span too much time on them because of the previous more important parts.
So I do rely on the org community and the contributors to implement these new features
and my idea is that I want to direct which features and how they should be implemented
but the actual people who implement them should come from the community.
Now let's go into the details. The code base. As a bit of motivation I would like to share this
email from Wichest Poman who years ago asked about improving org mode by making it more modular.
So that's directly ask about improvements or foundations of the code and that's what might
you have what I think is important direction as well. Here is an example. We have a lot of really
really large org libraries like org.io which is like one megabyte or something or org agenda,
org table, org east and a number of parts which are really really large and what is worse they are
hard to understand sometimes. I even have an example that an author of our complaint that
he part of his motivation to write org yell and specifically his agenda part,
a gentle light part was because org agenda is so hard to understand that it's easier to start
from scratch. I don't want such situations to happen in future if possible at all so one of the
projects I am currently working on is working progress now is splitting live org libraries into
smaller parts into more documented parts into the APRs which are actually documented and explained
in the code at least so that people who just open org mode code cannot be scared away and go and read
the comments and understand what is happening that easier. At this point I have like almost doubled
the number of libraries it's still working progress so there is a lot of room for improvement in this area.
Another direction which is somewhat reasonable in relation to splitting things down
is that some libraries are really generically not moved because org mode often has a functionality
which is really new and for that it had to implement some very unique functionality that doesn't
have to be used just for more this can be generalized for EMAX in general. So there is a number of
libraries which we may or may not upstream to EMAX depending on what EMAX my internet think.
As one example is org capture because it's very obvious example org capture started to support
from remember dotial which is still a part of EMAX so it has more features than remember dotial which
were required for org but you know these features can be backwarded why not and then we can
not only org mode but other EMAX libraries can benefit from these features we have in org now only.
Similarly I have I can have a long list of different libraries that can be shared.
Yeah but some I'm not sure but in general there is a lot of work that may be done and may be discussed
in the future. Third priority about the basics is making use of the new EMAX libraries.
EMAX in general is quite well written in terms of EMAX integration. We do support many of the
EMAX features and libraries which are generic. However in more recent EMAX versions we start
to get in some new features and we do want to make use them in org. For example recently we
contributed Yant Media support for clipboard based in drug and drop so now it is supported in
org mode already in the release release version and eventually we want to support transient dotial
because now org uses a network system and it's of course much better to use existing and more powerful
menus which implement an impatriation. It even has some initial work and progress implementation.
I hope it can be eventually extended to the whole org.
There are other things like compatibility which there is an excellent EMAX library
compact dotial that provides a backwards compatibility and org also has something like this in org
compact and we don't have to write it ourselves again. We can make use of the existing libraries in
large recent very very new library track changes for tracking changes in real time and eventually if
you want to support context many more maybe touchscreen, one Android support I don't know but I
hope it can be done by someone and some modernary leverage listing at that point.
That's about using external APIs. Now about the internal org APIs. One important
probably one of the most important parts of org is the parser, how org itself understand the org
files and the situation is that we have two parsers in org mode. One is the org element, the
proper parser which we use as a reference but many parser works still using regular expressions
which are approximated. So like these two parsers are not exactly consistent which is really bad
and I hope to solve this. So I always started doing some work by factoring all some part of
abstract syntax tree and working on real time parser, incremental parser which is enabled by default
in organizing but there's still parts which I need to work on and eventually I want to catch
the ease of regular expression based parser completely so that we don't have any inconsistencies inside
org mode. One of the examples of this pars that I still use in regular expression is quantification
which is often simple one, especially in some edge cases and we really want to use the proper parser
in this area. Maybe even editing org files using the parser syntax tree but that might be tricky
although there is existing library that implements some ideas from here for this.
The key point is that org element API, the parser where it should eventually be used to
revise so that everything is consistent. The second important API is the org label.
Currently org label does have some API but both is not well documented. Second, it's sometimes
awkwardly designed, especially compared with the exporter. So I do want org label APIs to be more
consistent. Another thing about org label is not exactly API but you know that the
documentation for most of the label backends are not even in the org manual even though
the backends are built in. They are not tricky and they do want to move them to the manual eventually.
That's important part and it should be done. Those are some obstacles like not all the features
are properly implemented and that's a bit of an extra votes to that should be done.
Another small thing which sends to Bruno or Pierre is being done in the progress.
We should have a more robust testing for an SAPI, for example. I hope it can progress further
from now it already progressed quite far. That's all about the basics, the underlying backbone of
the org hold base. So let's move to the second important direction which is
the third-party packages and basically the parsers for mobile apps. I will both point the community
to them because I want to have a focus on the user at that. So for third-party packages, I would like to
remind you that org mode used to have something called org-conch-trip as a part of org mode which is
a collection of small libraries, small packages that didn't have appropriate operators. I'm
in basically but more or less part of org mode. This is not only in the case. Now what we did
is we moved a number of very rarely used libraries from org couriers south to org-conch-trip
and now we treat org-conch-trip as basically the libraries that really want someone to take
responsibility for. We want the new maintenance for everything that is in org-conch-trip and from
me and other org team. We do not spend too much time maintaining this package, just do some
most basic backfixing and that's all. So if you see some libraries from org-conch-trip and you use them
and you know Elis, please volunteer to be my maintainer because otherwise there will be not much
progress in these libraries. As a natural extension of this and inspired by Tarsius or Imax
orphanage idea, we also maintain a small page basically listing the libraries, some others like
packages, Imax packages that are not really maintained. So if you are a maintainer of a library
and you don't have time to do it, you can write to org main list and we can add your library to
this page so that we can search for new maintainers in a more centralized way and if you are
Elis hacker and you want to help something for org mode, you can check that page and see
where you can help. Now away from Imax or mobile apps, we have quite a lot of mobile apps at this point.
Unfortunately it's very hard for me and many other Elis contributors to contribute to this app
because they are not originally Elis naturally but these applications heavily rely on org markup
and I do hope that we can keep org markup consistent enough and reach enough so that people don't
happen when extensions to org like what happened to mark them. So I really want to emphasize that
I want to see more org parses in different languages so that they can be used by developers
and for people who are writing these parsers, I want to share the link, it's the org syntax reference,
it is the official org syntax which what we think it should be, it's described in plain
human language is not a code and all details should be listed there so please use it as a reference
if you are writing the parser. Imagine this document will be submitted to iatf I hope and in the future
I hope to write a setup test which will work as benchmarks so basically we have some existing
tests for our internal parser and I want to factor out this test so that can be used by any parser
so that we can compare the performance and which parts of org mode are parsed and which parts of it.
I mentioned that we want to submit to iatf which means that org markup will become the actual
registrars format but before we do that and thus fix org markup in the stone because it's very
hard to change since in the iatf it's important to address important problems
existing problems with org syntax there are some problems like I mentioned the inconsistencies
between the two existing parses in our mode there are also some parts like there are some examples
like the problems with numeric priorities for example which are not treated consistently
and the problem is more general problems with org syntax when people request some edge cases
which should be addressed like it's very very hard to do into a org markup and like we have zero
means space work around but many people dislike it so maybe we want to do something about it
we have some edge cases when we combine and process these links we have some edge cases and we have
double blank lines inside some source blocks for example and combination in the list
and I hope we can somehow address it it's it's not impossible to do it as request time one annoying
part is the inline time syntax it's annoying pause from the programming perspective internally
as implementation and from the neural perspective because there are too many stars and we probably
should redesign it eventually maybe in backwards compatible way but we will see how it goes
another part is not just fixing the edge cases or problems is the new completely new syntax features
that's probably done after the simulator area but there are important things that people
open request like timezone support in timezone better repeaters like more flexible repeaters
that we can that that's really frequent request also another idea is some custom markup
which is coming to various requests like for example people often ask to
highlight some words it is a color for example or it's like some other special way and
then export it in special way just as we do with special blocks basically so what I want to
introduce is the ability to do it on markup or inline the pause new syntax feature which I
wish we could have is the multi line cells in tables it's very frequent request as well but I
really have no clue how to do it it's like we had we had a discussion about this and there were
previous discussions but there was no conclusion we don't see a good way how to implement it syntax wise
so unlike time zones where we decided exactly the syntax how it could be and we just
need batches to be submitted here even the idea of syntax is not clear so please do participate
in these discussions if you have ideas the last direction is the new features and in general
I welcome all kinds of good features but there's certain things which I explicitly want to see
and I hope to see submitted so if you are interested please do submit batches
one and probably many people aware about it is the asynchronous latte preview they're open by
too much encoding I hope it can be finalized eventually and the upstream it is pretty much
in registered but on the technical level it should be discussed further and revised the second is
or kill by Adam I hope it can get summed so it's also work in progress it's just a question of
pre-time for Adam most I think and me or that's another important part new feature
this already is the so-called multi-page expert the idea is the same as many packages for blog posts
so that you have a single org file and then you can export multiple HTML pages for example
or PDF pages or anything like that this work in progress by arm thanks for him
although it was a little bit stung because I am not exactly sure how to best integrate it into
existing APIs so if you are a developer of one of the blogging packages I would appreciate if
you can chime in and probably share some ideas here next are the some wishes I wish we could have
but it is not very detailed like one is the multi-language support so that we can have
work documents in multiple languages or maybe when translations and the collaborative
addition that people many people would wish to have I think like things like tracking changes
have had in comments importing from some other org from us with the comments and changes so that
we can actually participate with all those Microsoft Word users and stuff like that
but that's really too much for me alone to handle so if you want to see one of these features
please consider contributing just write a mailing list about your interest and we can start from
there now the important part is you see I keep asking people like please contribute please
contribute but who should contribute so I want to improve communication between the community
and the mailing list now people open discuss new features or ideas on all kinds of places like
credit, mastodon like all kinds of mathematics are such as you know meetups some non-English language
that's very nice that we have this community but not all the ideas are visible to the developers
so I do do wish that the most important things that people want to see should end up on the mailing
list one way or another and I'll later talk about the summary is how I think it can be done
and another part is we have org wiki and I hope that we can make it more centralized space for
interesting org mode articles for tutorials for blog posts at least link to blog posts so if you
have some idea about good blog posts it would be nice if you submit a patch to work or at least
email about this link to the mailing list of course people not everyone likes to use mailing lists or
don't have a good setup to do it or even don't want to read everything on org mailing list because
there are things like bug reports people don't really want to see that so bastion actually
developed a tool that can help with this so if you want to monitor org mailing list and
but want to see only the most important discussions and maybe participate if you decide to you don't
have to register we have a book which is basically a web page that monitors or mailing lists but not
every mail does the most important nonsense some blog like posts or feature requests or some
discussions and then on this web page you can see it as HTML or you can subscribe to this
air says or even download in Oracle MD format. Thanks to Saturday to you as are also weekly news
about image in general but org must as well it also includes the new new features in our mode
on the development branch and the interesting new blog for post and discussions on various
the credit forms or mailing list everywhere. I did this little bit of experimental integration so
that mailing list can also be read kind of announced on the charts so for example in magic or
mode metrics room we have a book that connects to woofer assess so that all the news and
discussions are notified in the chat so that interview people can see if they are interested
and maybe hopefully participate. I wish we could also have similar kind of boss for read it must have
done on maybe RC that way we have mailing list connected to them more active and like more modern
forms and the charts so more people exposed to what is happening.
Another part is that we actually have web interface to org mailing list and you can even
reply from there but it's not always obvious unfortunately we have the
public inbox software to transform the mailing list into HTML pages and that's a decent interface
but it could be improved to look more form like so that people can easily find a reply button or
basically participate without too much effort even if they are not subscribed or they are just
currently reading. That would be nice if someone knowledgeable of CSS could help with this.
Again I cannot emphasize more that most of the org ideas of the new pictures
coming from people but open they are they got they are known either by some submission
in the parts to mailing list or submit an idea to mailing list and rarely it happens when someone
is reading post from ready to then share to the mailing list so if you think that there is some
important deal discussion happening on the port it would be nice that you can go ahead and
share it with org mailing list and we don't care about this like on topic off topic because
like you must that all we don't focus on development we can discuss some related to org
mode topics in the org mailing list just like on an ordinary report.
I would like to end my talk with the call for contributed for contributions. Let me explain
a little bit because you saw now I I shared many many ideas and I just found a lot of time on
org mode in fact like for for the last year I was finding like 30 hours per week or something
until the promise that I can spend a bit less but still even with that much of commitment
there is no way I can handle everything by myself so it's we really really need more people to
contribute so that org mode keeps moving forward and again I just shared ideas but I have some
many more I have more than 1000 ideas not to down yeah there's no way I can do it to myself
so I do need help for new contributions for new pictures if someone can help fixing but it would
be really great if someone know specialized things like for example open document format
which I don't know very well it would be really nice because things like audit the expert
require knowing that and if someone always has emotions it would be much easier to if that person
can help research things. Also in the coming years it's very important to have regular contributors
because my life is my life and things may happen so it would be nice to have some kind of backup
so that bugs keep being fixed and things like patches being accepted and stuff like that so that
some person can at least temporary take on my job yeah and I would like to emphasize that the
content contributors are the most important contributions or more all the other types are
less important really so I want to spend a couple of slides trying to motivate you to contribute
if you have if you ever consider it contributing or if you ever wish some to have some
cliche in our mode really don't wait because most most new features are contributed by people
they are not contributed by me I contribute few things but I am alone I cannot contribute many things
so most of the things are contributed by users who go ahead and submit patches
and even in both very commonly requested features it's usually someone who step up
so if you want something don't wait. Just go ahead right to my list you don't have to submit
partially immediately you can just say I am interested and I will start from there
yeah we'll start because that's my job and I will guide you through if you have
a productious organ channels I will explain because that's what I know and I will explain how to
implement things better but I need someone to actually do the job and write the code
even if you don't if you are not like exactly Elis, if you don't have 10 years experience
with Elis it doesn't matter you can learn on the way there are many examples of this in the
many list when we start slowly fix since one by one and eventually arrive to a good code even
the person is not experienced you just need to be ready to learn things spend your pre-time
that's as usual right and have the interest in specific thing you contribute don't be afraid to
be wrong I will be there to assist if you don't like emails if you don't like patches it doesn't matter
again you can share get get habling it's okay and you can go and modify some of what directly you
submit the multiple version it's also okay it's easy for me to create patches if I need to
if you don't like emails at all you don't want to participate in the many list it's all it's
not ideal but I can still work with this I am on RC animatrix you can ping me it's
you know time 92 we also have monthly meetup so you can go and ask by what we can just talk
in person discuss your ideas is also fine so the key point is that I always welcome new contributors
the more contributions toward mode is better to increase the motivation I just try to
show some benefits of contributing to all mode and free software in general it can be actually
useful for your CVPR programmer it doesn't matter that it is a list because you know like you can have
a bad project that demonstrates your skills that you can finish something to a usable state maybe
but a bad project usually demonstrate that you can work alone but it doesn't demonstrate anything
about your work in the team in the production team but when you contribute to leverage software
look I will work with a number of people who contribute and comment on your work
we'll have to learn the new code base you'll have to follow certain standards and all these things
by having a public record of contribution will be a valid point that prove your knowledge in your CV
I put a small quote which I'm not going to read in the interest of time from Rudolf Alemktovich
who is actually who is describing these three points in probably most of the first full way
yeah another benefit is you can actually get money from this thanks to a number of
org mode users who kindly contribute to org development we have some out of money
coming in and we don't hold on this money if we get another person who contributes to org regularly
we are happy to share this money because we do know that getting some maximum even a little bit
does improve motivation so we are really ready to share this so if you are serious about
contributing you can actually you can just request this and we can share a part of the nations to you
phenomenon programmers we also have a lot of work to do it's a lot of stuff we can do on the work
weekly especially with CSS styles with improve like updating articles with adding links to tutorials
even writing tutorials about org mode it would be nice to have more screen because it would be nice
to improve org manual because that's the most difficult part for me because I'm too familiar with
the code but writing the manual when you know it internally it's very hard I just know too many things
I can assume that people know too much that the new users have no idea about certain things
and I can just meet those without being aware
and the final slide is that I would go to come back about the nations so again most important
is contributing code but I do hope that the nations can increase the number of contributors
and I don't know I know for sure because some people activity who is participating in this
he did find the nations helpful especially for more boring stuff like bug fixing and to move things
when over the long time so if you cannot contribute by other means it would be appreciated
by to contribute money and we came to the end of my talk and thank you for your attention
if you have any questions please feel free to ask think we can even discuss further during
the next org meet up in the coming week so there are if you have more detailed questions we can
continue discussing apart from what happens after this presentation